chaque allée maurice dantec
comment ça va réserver ses revenus
étaient perdus
comment ça va maurice
combien quelle impression ça vous fait
d'être au coeur de cet occident décadent
que vous avez quittez l'impression ouais
un peu dévastatrice ouais mais ça va
très très bien
alors bon soir publié chez albin michel
cosmos incorporated alors le pitch
voulais je le fasse comme vous voulez
dieu le faire vous me direz si je me
trompe pas je suis sûr vous aurez des
choses a ajouté
est-ce qu'on peut éviter d'avoir l'air
froid qui arrive comme ça sont adroits à
bannu c'est juste l'un vers ce qu'on
souhaite
non mais bon en même temps vous voulez
changer de place mais ça va très belle
émission
alors voilà donc le pitch du bouquin de
maurice allons-y
ok sur terre aux environs de 2057 après
quatre décennies de chaos orchestré par
le grand jihad le monde est dirigé par
une immonde humain c'est un protectorat
ultra sécuritaire où les machines ont
pris la place des hommes et dans ce
monde il ya un type qui s'appelle sergei
pote keane qui est un cyber tueur à
gages dont la mission s'est d'assassiner
le président d'une ville qui s'appelle
grande jonction voilà mais pendant la
préparation du crime et des événements
qui vont le détourner de son objectif et
il va découvrir en fait qu'il est en
réalité l'instrument d'un ange envoyé
par dieu dont le but est de délivrer la
terre de l'emprise des machines voilà
une excellente beach alors il ya un truc
très intéressant c'est que ce type bon
il est il est pas si c'est pas un humain
normal personne dans le roman est humain
c'est c'est la définition du livre si
vous voulez c'est que en 2057 on sera
passé au moment où
je veux dire l'humanité ça transforment
effectivement une prothèse d'une
certaine manière sociale et organiques
des machines
ouais et ce type donc qui est pas un
humain qui était programmé reprogrammé à
un moment son cerveau bugs et il a des
interférences dans son cerveau ne
comprend pas très bien
il reçoit des phrases de boussu et il
reçoit des phrase de l'évangile selon
saint luc il reçoit des phrases qui sont
carrément latin est quelque chose qui
est qui interfèrent avec son esprit et
en fait on découvre que dans ce monde là
dans l'ue ni monde que vous que vous
décrivez maurice
il y à des clandestins
il ya des rebelles des catholiques
clandestins des chrétiens rebelles 1
c'est le retour christianisme primitif
d'une certaine manière est et celui des
catacombes
oui si vous voulez j'ai essayé de
statuer sur le fait que la fin du monde
ne serait pas un événement spectaculaire
jaillir hollywoodien
ça sera la fin de l'homme comme le
décrit bénichou foucault en même temps
ce sera la fin de la technique ce sera
le moment où la science et la technique
vont progresser si j'ose dire à rebours
cyr le moment où la technologie
elle-même va s'autodétruire
on appelle ça autophagie excusez moi
d'amour un peu compliqué c'est à dire
qu'elle va se manger elle mène à basseau
tous les packs au site et ce fargo cité
elle-même
donc voilà le personnage central que
vous décrivez sergei diego que plotkin
est effectivement un cyborg soi-disant
programmée par une mafia mondiale
puisque le monde est aux mains à la fois
de cette agence de gouvernance mais
c'est en même temps un reflet du monde
dans lequel nous vivons n'est ce pas
c'est à dire que nous avons de cette
grande agence censée nous garantira la
paix et qui en fait nous promet la
guerre de tous contre tous plus donc
j'ai essayé d'imaginer quelle pouvait
être la perspective final de tout ça et
la perspective finale 20 6 blessés le
grand mur de glace ce qui nous attend
installés autour de 2050 effectivement
alors il faut dire que depuis que le
grand jihad a eu lieu dans dans votre
bouquin sur la terre la religion
catholique le judaïsme le protestantisme
sont interdits oui j'ai essayé
d'imaginer comme je vous disais un monde
qui partait à rebours il semblait
comment dire logique que les religions
monothéistes finissent par être
interdite
surtout si l'uni monde humain a décidé
de fabriquer j'allais dire c'est son
slogan un monde pour tous avec un dieu
pour chacun un
étrangement je regardais michel
houellebecq qui hier à la télévision qui
lui décrivait l'apparition d'une
religion unique sur la terre
moi ce que je décris plutôt celle
inverse c'est l'explosion individualiste
d'une fausse transcendance qui sera en
fête des religions bricoler que chacun
des religions parfaitement c'est
exactement ça des religions en kit
d'ailleurs on envoie j'allais dire les
prémices n'est ce pas un bon que ce soit
par les sectes ou par d'autres
mouvements métapolitique alors on
retrouve dans ce bouquin maurice votre
parano l'islamisation de l'europe
la dissolution de l'occident oui
1 oui vous craignez ça je le crains pas
je sais que ça va arriver c'est tout
ouais si vous voulez ça commence au
kosovo les églises brûle tous les jours
au kosovo ouais voilà
mais personne n'en parle visiblement
c'est peut-être pas politiquement
correct tu sais pas c'est pas très grave
si les églises brûle et le problème
auquel on assiste aujourd'hui c'est à
dire à la transformation post moderne de
l'islam en une idée on une idéologie
meurtrière me semble effectivement le
plus grand danger qui pèse aujourd'hui
sur l'humanité de la même manière que le
communisme pendant 50 ans l'avait été le
national socialisme il avait été
auparavant
ouais c'est tout vous avez eu des
parents communistes c'est sa voix la
guérilla oui on va dire que j'ai été
vacciné à ces jeunes un cette
perspective de l'islamisation de
l'europe de la dissolution de l'occident
vous ont amené à partir vivre au canada
oui vous dites pour éviter à ma fille
d'être là proie des betteraves ou
ramasser
j'allais dire on va attaquer direct quoi
vous ramassez la sphère du du bloc
identitaire et tout ça non soyons clair
vous avez communiqué avec le bloc qui
dans la serre vous avez échangé avec eux
vous avez effectivement oui alors à ce
niveau là je pense qu'il faut dire deux
choses le projet camilla faut dire que
c'est un groupe d'extrême droite extrême
droite dont l'un des membres a failli
assassiné ce pauvre avec une carabine 22
long rifle incarne un 14 juillet s'il
voulait lee harvey oswald lui même se
serait marais est bon comment vous dire
vivant au canada et lisant les nouvelles
apprenant que des jeunes filles se
faisait carbonisé vivante pour être
jetés dans des bennes à ordure que des
jeunes filles se faisait violer
collectivement de manière systématique
dans les cités moi ça m'a rappelé
précisément j'allais dire linverse une
certaine manière ce que j'avais vu en ex
yougoslavie ou comme vous le savez
l'armée serbe s'est quand même conduite
manière assez abominable en violant
collectivement deux jeunes femmes
musulmanes croates
hélas si vous voulez ben écoutez je vais
vous le dire cash pour moi ça sent le
brûlé
ouais voyez rien non bâti qui préfèrent
ils préfèrent l'accent québécois
j'ai quand même ce qui est pire c'est
pas pire acqua di gio faire croiser des
musulmans c'est l'accent québécois
j'ai voulu
j'avais remarqué ça lors d'une émission
précédente vous savez thierry oui mais
l'accent québécois c'est simplement
l'accent des gens qui ont colonisé
l'amérique au xviiie siècle qui venaient
de l'ouest de la france
ah oui c'est sûr les provoque look
effectivement qui ont conservé l'accent
qu'ils avaient ou xviie ou xviiie siècle
l'ex quelques innovations venue de
l'anglais si j'ose bilan pitoyable
comment nous aiderons par laquelle
courait l'accent paris j'aurais
tellement mieux
genre je parle c'est vrai et ça vous
connaissez des musulmans sympa oui mais
je vous en appelez